[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not gonna lie to you I've got better
intros in my life Jesus Christ that was
the most [ __ ] anticlimactic lay
welcome to this venue with four walls in
the ceiling so it has to pay property
tax
it is built let's take the [ __ ]
interview that's like the intro I used
to get a college gigs and then they have
some [ __ ] student go up there they
say your [ __ ] name first I supposed
to say the name last it [ __ ] Sunday
at the bat bat please welcome Billy
[ __ ] right they wouldn't do that they
started off they just go a comedian a
stage chinese-built bar well th wide
areas just walk on to nothing
I'm supposed to be ignoring you guys
like you're not [ __ ] here this is
supposed to be the podcast supposed to
be my goddamn bedroom you guys are
supposed to be the [ __ ] chatter and my
goddamn head we'll see how long this
works how long you guys can stare at
somebody laying on a leather couch
talking to themselves I think this was
from the Cornell Hall of Fame by the way
this is the original the original one
you know back when you could take your
dick out shake it in a woman's face and
there was no ramifications no
you didn't have to go in an apology tour
for taking it out you know ladies not
for nothing technically it is out you
know it hangs off your body so to just
go that extra centimeter through your
zipper I know you don't understand what
the big deal is all this sensitive here
in Phoenix somebody got in some water I
think they were in the Sun too long
it's the advocating rape do I need to
vlog about this can I sit down in the
middle of it make it about myself I
literally saw two women on Twitter
[ __ ] talking about a topic they was
sick of being asked about to each other
on Twitter it's like hey stupid you guys
ever consider exchanging cell phone
numbers but why don't you start with the
DM no you guys all [ __ ] Millennials
see discuss everything on public just
all has to be done how great is that
bomber in the fan I [ __ ] love that
guy Jesus Christ talk about a guy just
on a mission you know what I think where
they call that [ __ ] when you have to get
your vision board you just put
everything that you want to happen he
had that all over his van it's just like
trumps the [ __ ] [ __ ] CNN everything that
he visualized that all came true till
those Medellin cops had to come in and
ruin it it's like a [ __ ] scooby-doo
episode of just like shaggy snapped
he's [ __ ] killed everybody else and
forgot where he put his dog you know who
sucked it very hanna-barbera about it
you know he's politically active did you
get mad at that
[Music]
how can you say that in a post-911
vinegar today I think in today's climate
somebody [ __ ] asked me that one more
[ __ ] time what's it like to do that
today the climate once I don't use to
walk around telling you what to talk
about
sorry that was joke was just for me it
was just a man out the person's face
right at my [ __ ] head did you whisper
nicely in my ear afterwards I'll tell
you what I'm talking about
anyways yeah we're just gonna blame this
[ __ ] bomber right we're doing having
the American dream right the guy
basically it doesn't have two nickels to
rub together no one knows his [ __ ]
name all he has is just a white van
right could even afford something with
color barely just it's just primer with
the basic white I'll take that the vinyl
seats nothing in back just hearing his
belongings every time he takes a turn go
for one side of the band for the other
you know you know woman in his life she
walked out right yeah she was believing
in him till she got the van so there was
no more seats and she's just like oh he
doesn't want kids I'm out
I can't block this guy down the best I'm
going to get is [ __ ] alimony right
there's gonna be no child support that's
where the money's at right yes the
sixth-grade of the kid then you feed a
popsicles get yourself some shoes
that's how you do it that's how it's
done in Arizona it's why there's all
these fake tits out here try this all
these fake tits out here that is all
money that was supposed to be spent on
children's education and we said women
are using it try to beef up their chests
like you know like a bass fisherman
putting a better [ __ ] thing on the
hook right make fake [ __ ] titty just
wait for some guy a couple of scotches
in in this [ __ ] steakhouse right and
a good round of golf next thing you know
you bring those laminated [ __ ] things
out what's he supposed to do huh not be
a gun all right so now he's got his dick
up but it's under the bar right still
it's still legal in 2018 right you know
golf pants might as well hand it out
anyways right that's why Pete Cara wears
the Dockers right he does he walks
around half hard during the game that's
why he's always goes it's just a field
what are you so excited about I got my
doctor's on every time there's a greased
little [ __ ] wind shear my pubes stand
up and attention you guys don't watch
NFL Films so anyway just [ __ ] guys
sitting there who's goddamn bad right I
love we went out there to really I
really did you know what I mean I just
[ __ ] around you know now maybe
celebrities will shut the [ __ ] up
Jesus Christ these [ __ ] idiots this
spotter the Niagara Falls every day over
eight millions of gallons of water are
wasted you can collect that water with
poor poor children
we could eradicate polio right it's just
like just learn your lines
and go down to the SEC nobody comes you
know I didn't know who I was gonna vote
for the last election until I heard
somebody from what is it my favorite
Martian what's that show at the [ __ ]
nerds [ __ ] this three guys is a hot
blonde and nobody bangs or we paint
there yeah the Big Bang Theory somebody
with three lines on that show really
broke down [ __ ] uh the Iraqi war
formulas like it only makes a lot of
sense if anybody remotely famous is
listening to this all you're doing
you're not changing anybody's mind on
your doing is is your your your
kick-starting the dreams of a man with a
two-seater that's all you're doing
and what world does Robert De Niro
actually get a bomb sent to his house he
was populate is this Martin [ __ ] with
me are we doing another casino can't be
real I mean come on just I'm just an
actor insulted them a little bit salt a
little bit dick you [ __ ] popped off
your mouth thanks a bunch
he's a white like a bunch of interface
they forget thing from summer stock it's
like you play a tough guy
[ __ ] eight-year-old gonna go get a
[ __ ] colostomy and whatever the [ __ ]
it's called right speaking of which yeah
I turned 50 I'm Junior oh yeah back in
the day you got a gold watch in a horny
stewardess turns 50 maybe a cute steak
if they were the [ __ ] Midwest but on
the coast we got a [ __ ] stewardess
from pan and right she rocked your
[ __ ] world and everything was great
but now not today's hashtag America
really again what do you get you get
some [ __ ] broccoli this she tasted
stuff and you got to get a colonoscopy
so like I got one yeah obviously I'm not
dying I woulda brought it up and all I
was doing I just kept making jokes about
it cuz that's what you can do as a guy
right
I just kept saying in my wife I just
kept saying hey remember you got to give
me a ride so in front I just kept
calling the shotguns go up the Esso
literally a [ __ ] camera crew like the
shoot your ass it's all about yeah so
it's actually you know if you're up that
age you suppose the reason why I did it
was because I hadn't [ __ ] you know I
didn't have a kid
you know I would have been happy to just
[ __ ] it just keep going like Vince
Lombardi was 62 yeah my wife could
figure it out she's a big girl
scrap the kid you gotta do the right
thing so you know whatever so the
hardest part if there's any guy hit put
it off like a [ __ ] eh you know on this
whole school before with guys right then
you say do up around a burning trash can
take this post we even Frankie Valli and
the four seasons
hey no gunshot no [ __ ] camera my age
right now I would swim like that it's
just the stuff you have to drink and
what it does to you [ __ ] your body
that's that's the only part other than
that you just go there you know and then
you just they put this this [ __ ]
thing on you and they look like you
don't freak be honest II like fifty
times think they go we just gotta ask
you a couple of questions they ask me
everything after well it's a company
more [ __ ] questions like you know
like a little confidence do you have in
your ability here like if you get on a
plane with some guy eats the pilot you
know how much do you weigh yeah go ahead
[ __ ] [ __ ] alright cool you get
airsick this time cool it's a hey how
much did you say your weight
[Music]
that's where they kept doing it just
like do you guys like not want to
[ __ ] do this today I don't need to be
here I can take this thing out of fun so
no you literally just get there and they
just put this [ __ ] on you now I'm gonna
tell you think they tell you to lay on
your side which is really that that's
gonna keep the dreams close then you
just you just can't give in you just
take two deep breaths that's it then it
feels like a second later you just wake
up and the person just like all right
you're good you're not gonna die then I
recommend not talking because you're
still under the influence buried in your
[ __ ] colon about a minute ago so
anyways I am going to game for right now
for those listening to this stuff that's
right I am a Phoenix Arizona right now
and I've got me game for the world
series everybody here remembers the
World Series and you guys want one or
two thousand one right - who doesn't
want that's right 2001 that's right
because it was 9/11 and everyone I oh my
god we feel so bad for New York do you
like well what about us go back for us
you know Colorado River insides running
dry
we don't like Martin Luther King very
cold water if you don't know [ __ ]
love down here you went down there you
beat you beat you made Arizona happy and
the rest of the country said to this day
to this day the championship fairy does
not come around and tapped you on the
head a sense to you guys apologize for
your flank disrespect of all the victims
of that I'm not talking about the people
that died that day I'm talking about the
people that watched it on television and
made it about themselves all of those
people
oh my god I was in Connecticut and I
just feel like for me I don't even want
to leave my house well don't sweetheart
don't leave the house turn on the stove
and hide in there
why don't you what you say that you
trying to be a better man I'm not aware
of too many things I don't have a
concern for the next five years
judging by the uncomfortable laughs
there's a lot of guys in here that needs
to go get that petition which might make
children wide sweetheart that's rich
there was a video game of lions who have
left there's only so many times you can
be like the guy says what he needs to do
you still got a pile on with that little
[ __ ] right as we go the lead yeah okay
you're right well good maybe next time
you should think [ __ ] agree with you
it's gotta get that one last order you
know why that is for so many of them
have never been punched in the nose
that's what it is what it is
no makes you better person you survive
it makes you better makes you think oh
oh maybe I shouldn't say that
maybe I should just sit here and enjoy
my tea see advocating domestic violence
yes there's too many people I don't know
how to get rid of people but the best of
islets seems to be away what else yes I
want to go to 8/4 yeah I don't know it
games played out here with Phoenix
people I've never really been to a game
where I was wearing the opposing teams
Jersey I know you guys know whoever just
you know go to college seriously maybe
the are red shoe your parents are going
to be rich 21 of these zombies right
outside the club here think this really
is one of the most underrated scary
downtown's I know it is like in a
[ __ ] instant the second the workday
is over
it goes from Maybury it's weird because
what you know that that happens it's
like during the day you gotta quit your
eyes to look through the matrix and all
these happy people what places to go
home to oh yeah yeah this is Johnny's a
homeless guy you'll notice it's not the
homeless it's not the drug addicts it's
it's the legit crazy people they're
really scare me no and I can tell you
when I was a kid you didn't see them you
know I mean you saw like homeless people
you saw it junkies but you didn't see
this [ __ ] shutter island' [ __ ]
[Music]
like Mike Meyers type [ __ ] walking
down the street that's because when I
was a kid they used to have not houses
we're crazy you got sent to the Niles
and your parents they didn't protect you
they were just like yeah I'm out of here
you know back then people had like eight
or nine kids so they didn't mind at the
state came by took one and they talk
about yeah that was the original ending
to the waltz that's when they call that
show eight is enough
big fan pat was like take Nick one of
these [ __ ] get into a [ __ ] enough
shows why the women too because that's
bad but he can be proud of having a son
he's gonna carry on my name even if that
gulbadan out right [ __ ] to jump
behind in thighs right this is a moment
like that is such an absurd thing I just
said and every guy in here got scared to
laugh at like that's how nervous people
are and I like at me to talk my junk
behind my thighs I would absolutely do
it because she is a strong woman and I
support her I still have my job did I
say the right thing my dreams don't come
true
[Music]
I've thought about crazy thing this is
one of the other podcast goes people
it's just just be meandering from one
subject to another that's alright okay
goes once me I know if she was doing
that or she was making like a pizza
crust yeah but you know what have a few
younger people right somewhat I'd
probably do it will stay that a little
bit you see you guys are [ __ ] see
what's going on the other people say
first same woman there's one woman that
is excited about this show the rest you
I've loved into my podcast energy not
like when you were robbed yeah when I
was a kid they were like nuthouse but
what happened was the people who worked
it did not houses will [ __ ] the
patients then automate my weight on the
deal there's no nothing better than a
crazy person I'm just gonna keep going
harder the more serious
[Applause]
comedy hands I'm gonna go further than
this like yeah like link you're not in
the field go with me get inside for
Christ's sake take a [ __ ] ride did
you guys get any inspiration from that
[ __ ] bomber goofy and he'll be out
actually eleven years he comes out it'll
be like : give me a co-anchor I'm CNN
don't recon in it like my Vegas catches
a car counter after that's done breaking
his hands like I you want to work here
trying to catch other pieces of [ __ ]
[Music]
every time there's a [ __ ] psycho
they're gonna wheel this guy on though
well I am you can't touch a Spanish
white and Thank You Ellen
[Music]
yeah you have to forgive and forget I
just think it's amazing that he was able
to make all those bombs and not blow
himself up in the kitchen
this guy's doing the same thing with a
bomb how nervous are you when you go on
the internet and you're googling how to
make a pipe bomb fight fitter class is
the bomb you gotta scroll like 10 pages
deep do you like some pipe fitter
there's another thing to do with
plumbing I want to be on the dark web
you guys have this one you gotta really
feel creepy your wife's asleep in the
other room now you kids sleeping but the
little noisemaker of [ __ ] birdies
[ __ ]
you're there in the dark
left to Steve just me this your soldiers
go into the [ __ ] computer I wonder
that like the internet isn't enough for
you he's got enough [ __ ] up [ __ ] it
will be some beheadings somebody's
taking the head sticking into somebody's
ass this internet it's not yes
it's not doing it for me my tolerance
just so [ __ ] high I need something
darker these Isis videos I mean why
don't you just put on [ __ ] Bugs Bunny
I have an animus
you got anything darker so watching
somebody from Scotland coming over here
drinking a beer on my podcast so they
come out here and talk [ __ ]
[Music]
so I still out here first time I flew a
helicopter since like August to my two
best [ __ ] landings I've had a long
[ __ ] time planning that [ __ ] like a
goddamn Daisy oh yeah oh yeah you should
I get a little [ __ ] and happy on the
[ __ ] on the footy Center you know to
me especially there's a tail when I go
go that there's a guide you in that's
when you get nervous he's bringing you
in then he tells you you know just set
the [ __ ] thing down so [ __ ] boy
should be maybe even 50 set it down like
a champ [ __ ] would blink so he walked
into this little Airport and as he's too
[ __ ] old timers just sitting in like
they gotta do a wine cooler commercial
for [ __ ] cigarettes then plain
[ __ ] crapped out and they just sit
there like they're not nervous these
guys you know these guys [ __ ]
probably to buy planes back
[Music]
well then how's it going like yeah you
know I'm not so good yeah [ __ ] attention
cut out on us you know whatever this
[ __ ] cigarettes you know like the
flip flop blew out or some [ __ ] so we
get the gas the [ __ ] thing up and
with done gases up now we're going to go
back up to the helicopter to start it up
from this [ __ ] [ __ ] pulls up in his
little Cessna nice plane and he parks
right next to us so now we can't start
us up because you know with the Windy
Creek they could flip its thing office
so we just say it and that nicely you
say hey man where we've taken off here
it is what's up s he goes yeah I'm
fueling up he just walked away dude he
was such a dick it was like inside you
know that somebody in real life was that
much of a dick it was like a coming of
age might afford a Steven Seagal movie
was at that level there was three of us
or what him hey we're taking up take it
off yet I'll fueling up turn this back
to us he didn't have a ponytail
with that guy he wasn't he was just some
[ __ ] dick and I just I don't know
who's just such he was such an [ __ ]
that I I actually like them now anytime
I meet somebody if they're the real deal
you're not amazed to see if it are
playing you just see the way holes at
guitar the waiting plays its home you
like that guy's the real deal even if I
got enjoys music I respect the guy
you're gonna get those anything you know
a bomber the funky make a pipe bomb have
a white bag if you hold manifesto on the
[ __ ] window you know there's no
auto-tune in that sing it to attract
that guy is the real [ __ ] that guy would
have tried to kill people in any era in
any other he wasn't doing it for the
likes on Instagram he wasn't trying to
turn himself into a situation you know I
came up with a bit the last time I was
here cuz that when I was scared about
the about the [ __ ] zombies coming out
I was working with virzi and it was like
a quarter to five like [ __ ] we got to
get something to eat you know before you
know before you know we become a part of
the menu here right
we went into that place it's like right
next door this sandwich place you know
one of these places just you know strong
paper on the floor you're gonna wipe the
table off with your sleeve just one of
those places where it's like oh I really
want to eat here it's like well I don't
want to fight zombies so yeah we was
sitting there and this lesbian came
walking in it always gets quiet when I
see that people always act like well hey
man like hi did you know she was a
lesbian
how did she know she was a lesbian
well the same way you look like a
Corvette guy you like pizza you make
judgments Asian guy not gonna say good
at math judging by your physique you
have too many white friends
[Applause]
but none of that [ __ ] we're setting a
bad wag nothing wrong with duck hunting
visits for vets or being an Asian guy
you know having a couple of white
friends that introduce you to the wrong
foods you gotta get back to the bok choy
dude I'm telling you that you gotta stay
away from the white flour you ever
wondered why white people are so evil
that's what it is it's coursing to our
mate yeah everybody thinks it's the
white privilige it isn't it's the truth
that's not true before GMOs people even
worse when we had the best food of the
planet right Johnny Appleseed eggs
you literally whitewash the [ __ ]
cents for an apple like that was a
desert I'm a Tom Sawyer oh boy oh boy
and painted so feds I get a [ __ ] I
got an apple maybe see great shape
that's when he was so shocked when he
died he didn't have a [ __ ] ounce of
family so skinny he went to his home he
went to his own funeral you know that's
the level scheme that most women aspire
to be speedy they could be at their own
funeral and nobody sees in them and they
can see how people crying in their care
about
[Music]
yeah and it's so dedicated yeah this
weighs a couple empty seats here right
now this party of two out the rear side
of a dumpster
it's just involuntary reaction are you
making fun of this eating disorders yes
do I want it to happen to you no but it
is a subject I'm sorry if you thought
that was funny I just like that's where
I draw the line when it's something that
affect me that's where the line is you
can see Asian guy with white friend I
don't give a [ __ ] that's hilarious
that is funny to me is it lonely as an
Asian guy in Arizona you know all these
white guys walking around the golf
course they think you're on the Pro Tour
[Music]
sorry it's a really white state you guys
earned it all right I know you guys
treat minorities here I know you just
look at the Grand Canyon and keep it
moving
[Applause]
are Trump's on your snake flag next year
[Music]
no come on happy about it flora you know
like why don't you like them he's gonna
make you offense even stronger he's
doing something for you
oh god you better hope he doesn't do
this broadcast they can't a manager
that's gonna set terrible stain wouldn't
be surprised if this white fans headed
there right now it's Lyon all right
did I say everything here dick in
aviation Red Sox fat [ __ ] I was talking
about beep get back on that corner they
did my polka dance if we've got that
creepy guy over 50 where and a half sure
ladies you're the [ __ ] salt paprika
pubes just L shut up it's not my fault
you're eating all right let's get to the
questions by the way everybody thank you
so much for coming up
[Applause]
the only city I've ever done a live
podcast in this is the second time I
thought it
thank you guys you guys are great people
you know like those liberals in
California tell us what we want to hear
all right all right la la sports fan I
wear the blue shirt to bring out my eyes
by the way I'm telling you dude I'm
gonna get the [ __ ] hair plugs you
wait the next time I come why in Spain
I'm gonna look [ __ ] I'm not what go
either shine
what's that wig me they're not thin
enough no say they weren't good enough
yet good enough we said thin enough body
image in here I just talked about women
puking behind a dumpster gracefully walk
my way out of that you lead me right
back into that shirt is that what you do
that's alright it's alright it's alright
she's gonna [ __ ] choke all right la
sports pin and uh maybe think those
doctors will they give you Cosby they'd
be like tag inside of your color
you know they know who you going to next
they just right what's up Mike sorry if
anybody was involved in the procedure I
want to thank you for your
professionalism not for feeding the
inside of my digestive tract all right
la sports man a lot of [ __ ] jokes on
this one people sorry all right
hey really red face you get to watch me
read out loud I can't [ __ ] see anyone
hey really Red Sox face I'm tired of you
East Coast cuts come into my city and
talking [ __ ] about the sports culture
you know what's worse than the LA sports
culture all of you from out of state who
moved to Hollywood and soaked up
everything about the lifestyle out here
oh do we dominate the entertainment
industry sorry but walk around with your
Red Sox hats on talking [ __ ] about the
sports culture dude you guys earned it
then the [ __ ] worst
dude I swear wet stress up [ __ ] two
Yankees games at the height of the curse
of me oh yeah all he would do is break
balls that was it if you laughed about
it then you were cool anyway you from
the blah blah blah blah blah then they
say something about how do you like them
apples and it was over literally yeah
they like beat up a dad with this kid
standing there till he dies of brain
damage in this guy's action should you
guys making fun of this sports culture
I'm sorry I didn't mean to thank you by
bringing up the fact that you burners
fathers with children and baseball games
yeah you're right you're absolutely
right I should lighten up it'd be a
little more respectful speaking of which
I love wearing any Red Sox [ __ ] together
and I'm a part of this darker blue
[ __ ] t-shirt and sending the group so
we said so that some guy was put into a
coma a few years back parentheses and
eventually died for being a Giants fan
but that's a one in a billion chance
throw a parent shut up there is nothing
worse than Red Sox fans period everyone
in sports agrees let's go close doors
that's [ __ ] hilarious everyone agrees
7th grade girl hey you know if you're
alright with that you know killing a dad
in front of his children that I mean Who
am I to go to your state and Senate
that's not the way you're supposed to do
it take me out to the ball game take me
out to the crowd stop a [ __ ] dad's
head in front of his kids he wore judge
gear and that's what he didn't want
fault his kids cry it's a shame it's
[ __ ] ridiculous man he should lighten
the [ __ ] up everybody acting like
they're [ __ ] tough you're not tough
when you beat up a dad with kids I
really have to say that in 2018 what
sort of climate is out there so really
you can't take your dinner out of work
anymore but you can stop a dad
I will never understand Hollywood I just
I just maybe abyss maybe I should go
back east where things make a little
more sense to them alright we've had
everything we've had anorexia weekend
dense pumpkins number two girlfriend
compares me to her ex
[Music]
hey Billy wait nuts won't kill the Ryan
Deiss I always thought they worked
perfect like a bunch accidentally rolled
out I always thought we just look like
you know that's gonna be purple I don't
know why someone would like that
maybe she grew up watching Barney with
an absentee father all right all right
hey Billy went nuts
my girlfriend sort of told me that I
don't spoil spoil her and like her ex
did well you just found out why he
[ __ ] left all right Jesus Christ
gotta fix a red flag on a [ __ ] pig
[Music]
before she gets pregnant
thank you and all your [ __ ] dreams
that I do all right
go now you ran a [ __ ] wingman with no
seeds a couple of days ago we had a
little argument and she was like oh he
used to make me bubble baths take care
of me and every way possible
always made sure I was okay and
everything he goes keep in mind he'll
I've only known this girl for like two
months only what I would have been like
well then why don't you go back to him
he sounds like a great guy what did you
leave look for that would be his [ __ ]
Laura now and you're gonna blow B or
what some of the bubble bath in my pubes
I would just beat the odds [ __ ] road
to her she's being rude to you right
okay
where does your ex-boyfriend live how
about I pay for the uber and you come
and go over there and you tell us this
would you like to watch Netflix or go
over to his house anyways when I asked
her about the details she just say it's
okay I guess it's not in your culture
whoa wait a minute wait a minute what
movie we just jump some racial board is
there anyone ever said that
so Peter this is not in your culture and
what does that mean
never mind and then they do a secret
white guy handshake right front can you
really sleep peacefully as an agent and
Arizona is there a way to do it if you
haven't got a pocket a panic room that
you go into anyways anyways what should
I do
I try my best to be a great boyfriend
but this should just make me feel like
I'm not doing enough
any advice yeah get some [ __ ]
self-esteem and kick her to the curb
this is what you gotta do the next time
she says that everything that she
brought up I would buy it CVS bubble
bath candles all of that and put it in a
gift bag and just hand it to her just
say that there will be a [ __ ]
ex-boyfriends house it doesn't like you
go home and figure yourself to the
memory whatever identity that is your
fantasy and I am NOT it so see you later
so we don't yeah that's it yeah you
gotta kick her to a curb that's it
[ __ ] true alright it's number three
all right advice neighbor thinks I rock
this house
[Music]
alright I'm guessing that the end of
this story is going to be on cable
channel 249 whatever they run cops or
first 48 dear Billy Byrne last week a
police officer came to my door early in
the morning and asked me if I had heard
anything unusual the night before I
would have been like no like what we the
sound of an ax going to somebody's neck
who died
am i a suspect well then I'm going back
to bed that's the thing I learned in the
first 48 all you have to save the cops
is am I being charged with anything
if yes I want a lawyer if though I'm
going to leave but you can't do that in
real life into that real life because
cameras aren't on they just beat the
[ __ ] on you
[Music]
some cops can write it actually there
are cameras there's cameras with
everything we do it you know it's not
you if your coffee you're listening to
this I irritated you that is the point
of this podcast opportunity from Bolivia
to the police visibility one of the
[ __ ]
anyways he told me that my next-door
neighbors had been brought and I should
keep my eye out for suspicious activity
like what's something that can suit with
[ __ ] where when well somebody drunk
in a kiddie pool and the alcoholic and
the other side of it huh got suspicious
or is that just sad my neighbor let's
call him Phil is going through a nasty
divorce and it's known to be unstable
but not dangerous I don't know if I
would go that unstable is dangerous to
me that man has stable this is a
dangerous house yeah yeah I'm trying to
think of another [ __ ] thing like that
he's violent but doesn't hurt anyone
[Music]
the only tortures animals something
about forelegs he doesn't like joerger
in the clear just go home and ask them
what kind of movies in all right he
stays up all night drinking and replete
repeats a lot of monotonous tasks like
washing his car every day for hours on
end I think this guy's on met Jesus
[ __ ] Christ he lives alone doesn't
work never leaves his house for anything
but groceries and doesn't date women hey
there's nothing wrong with being gay
I know his daughters from high school
and he always asked me how they're doing
so I assume he has no contact with them
Jesus Christ you still talk to this
[ __ ] man I feel bad for him ah oh
this guy's going to be a victim I feel
bad for this unusual unstable but not
dangerous person who washes his car
every hour and has no relationship with
his own children do you think I should
make them a loaf of bread bring it over
yeah what did you just slit your wrists
to jump in a [ __ ] alligator pit in
the [ __ ] x-treme here just to make you
guys laugh I don't need it because I
feel bad for it so sometimes I go to his
house the first thing I thought about
was that woman that went over that
woman's house when she said her monkey
was acted weird it ripped her face
did you go up with you with your
night-vision goggles so you could follow
me to the basement so sometimes I go to
his house to try is cooking and listen
to a ramble on about things where is
this sympathy in this story for this
person you know it's like every time you
see a frosted bicycle right next to a
freeway Oh what happened
you brought your bike to traffic a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh sorry they know about people o people
have died on bicycles I'm not advocating
that I'm just saying it's not a tragedy
it's avoidable public transportation
uber anyways he's a nice guy with good
intentions but he could be he can be
pretty overbearing I find myself going
on it my way to avoid him because he's
always in his driveway and once they
have drawn out of conversations
regularly yeah well you [ __ ] up you
went over and talked to him crazy people
could not see you until you talked to
him you just walk by him literally
playing the [ __ ] tuba and it just
blends in with this [ __ ] it is his head
the second you talk to him then they
just they just think you're all they can
see he's gonna cut you up soon and stick
him in that bucket it's like I'm
watching you every day instead of his
car
I can tell he's offended by this now you
pissed them off but I worked through
jobs and often generally don't have time
to stop and check oh yeah anybody
anybody's everyday to this cycle you
cannot you cannot slowly back your way
out of the relationship you have to
vaporize just they live in Tampa you
have to go to Eureka California and be
off the grid you got to like go to
Colorado become like a kayak instructor
anyways my sister goes to supposed to
school with his youngest child who
apparently had been telling the kids in
their class that Phil had been held up
at gunpoint and zip tied to a chair in
its place during the alleged robbery be
sure the guy just wasn't jerking off
autoerotic self-impose no that's
absolutely preposterous to me we live in
a neighborhood of nice upper-middle
class condos at the suburb and it's very
easy to hear everything that's going on
oh Jesus Christ
but one of the keys and robbing a place
is to be quiet enough that people don't
hear you do you think the robbers are
just loud and people get robbed in the
inner city because of all the [ __ ]
construction in some ways and it doesn't
happen in the suburbs because it's so
quiet out anyways that seemed absolutely
my voice might out to my sister and left
it at death fast forward to today a
little over a week ago my sister tells
me that people at her high school are
saying I was the one who robbed him I
was not only shocked but angry that my
sister had to hear it from kids
class oh now this person's losing their
cool wait a minute
maybe you're the crazy one this is like
a great movie they led me all the way
down this road and wait a minute you see
dead people and you're dead I have a
seat fill the entire week since it
allegedly happened his car is in the
driveway and I could tell that he's home
this person's acting [ __ ] crazy this
all started because you went up and you
felt bad oh my god I feel bad
let crazy people be crazy all right let
the orderlies handle him all right bring
the [ __ ] shirt wrap his arms around
them yeah bring the adults swaddle the
[ __ ] straitjacket but anyways he
hasn't left his house do you think he is
suspicious of me or could it be it was
just a rumor that kids let get out of
hand I'm considering knocking on his
door and asking em if he thinks I robbed
this house this can't be real
but I don't want to do it on the ground
so some kid I don't even know said so
what should I do
I am at this [ __ ] ship set sail dude
like this is some I don't know what you
know what this is like I got this is
like [ __ ] Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire I'm gonna phone a friend and
that's this crowd this is too much legal
liability here alright okay so alright
I'm gonna I'm gonna bring difference
there is one all right if you think you
should just continue or she should just
continue to ignore this person and hope
that this whole [ __ ] thing just dies
if its own weight it gradually goes away
let's hear it yeah just clap alright
give me the book if you didn't agree
[Music]
all right
oh you watching in it you want to see
this person get [ __ ] up all right if
you think this guy a woman should go
over to this person's house knock on the
door and see if they do in fact have
some sort of a problem sons of [ __ ]
for the legal record I do not agree with
that if you think this person should put
their house up on Zillow immediately
[Applause]
pack up an overnight bag right now let
somebody else who looks like them sell
the [ __ ] house get to another
district anybody anybody yeah yeah there
you go I mean listen I what I would do
honestly is I would call somebody in law
enforcement tell them what you know and
ask their [ __ ] advice and I can tell
you why I'm gonna go out on a limb and
say nobody in law enforcement is going
to say to go over there and not love the
door to get to the bottom of his life
you think he's gonna do it anyway what
is it mother oh yeah yeah he's already
investing six re-invest like the way you
think in here he felt bad he's weak he's
a weak person
he's in the running [ __ ] but he was
in it he say his too long it was
entertaining oh I'm up oh I think I keep
snakes shenanigans you're in his own
[ __ ] burner would you call the first
48 the first 42 Nana gets turned into a
musical everybody's [ __ ] the funniest
cop all right penny soos all right what
up you redheaded [ __ ] up the 10/22
Monday morning podcast you talked about
taking your daughter to a petting zoo
yeah I didn't like that [ __ ] oh I always
kind of held her I'm not a helicopter
parent would like when you're around
[ __ ] animals dude you should've seen
the look on these [ __ ] folks faces
and had it they [ __ ] had it it was an
adult sitting there just stroking the
sprocket things beard like you know like
that's gotta be the equivalent of
robbing a biker gangs mohawk
so like plenty so fuzzy playing with his
wallet chain like what are you doing
these [ __ ] things we just [ __ ] man
eat his hay with this [ __ ] 600 yard
stare like I'm gonna [ __ ] do
something I don't know what I'm gonna do
they kept trying to climb up on it to
get away from moving [ __ ] you know
you know kids they just learned how to
use their arms so they don't know how to
bid like slamming their hands down on it
it's like a flare shot all right anyways
the buddy of mine went to a petting zoo
when he was five year old five years old
and he forgot to wash his hands before
he ate yeah I made sure we had the
[ __ ] the anti [ __ ] goat in my on
except he ended up getting salmonella
giving a horrible diarrhea
I've got permanent colon damage horrible
diarrhea
he got permanent Cola damage damage and
had awful shits for a decade my wife
tonight
I tried to tell him but you know I love
my wife she's the greatest thing that
ever happened but all my gonna read this
too when he was 16 his doctor told them
that they could solve the issue by
removing his colon long story
he doesn't have a call it anymore and he
has to shed about 20 minutes after a
meal because the [ __ ] doesn't have a
storage unit anymore the podcast pick it
up he's great the one that picks all the
great music on a Thursday just before
Friday Monday morning focus all right
the last one before I have to go this
has been a lot of fun let's see here
wait this says moon landing divorces
away is it right here all right dear
Billy Boy I recently was watching a
documentary about the Apollo moon Apollo
program main guidance computer which was
the smallest most complicated computer
that had ever been built I imagine up
until then the project was running
behind schedule so why the guys had to
work extra long hours for it to be
completed I was shocked to hear them say
that almost all of them got divorced
after that and pretty much blamed it on
the project I seriously can't believe
that anyone could divorce someone over
that I mean like your husband is
literally working on the most important
thing humanity has ever accomplished
cleaning about it not being around for a
few months what the [ __ ]
losing to the documentary if you wanna
watch thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
we know the deal listen we all have our
thoughts okay in women's sports or is
that they want the big house but they
think that you're still going to be
there to enjoy it they don't get the
case of mortgage that I'm getting when
you buy the big house you could be
walking by a pool you never go in they
don't bet that they think you're just
gonna sit there with them until they get
bored in that house you want a bigger
one that's what I do
[Applause]
posters after
bell rings good luck the Dynomax pitch
here let's take lender red Sun see you
later thank you for [ __ ] yourself
thank you thank you
awkward ending here thank you very much